so now it gets really good I already
covered how White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders when asked about
the White House's position on the
fairness and freeness of the recent
reelection of Russian President Vladimir
Putin she didn't answer she answered
questions that were not asked of her so
now let's pull Donald Trump in himself
to further our analysis which really
exposes once again just how disconnected
the White House is from any just
sensible and obvious criticisms of what
it is that took place in Russia during
the recent election the White House
announced that Donald Trump was not
going to be congratulating Vladimir
Putin on his election win and the reason
given was listen we've had these recent
nerve agent attacks there have been
election irregularities Donald Trump has
no plan whatsoever to congratulate
Vladimir Putin on his election win okay
that that actually seems like a
reasonable position that seems good
Trump then gets on the phone with
Vladimir Putin and immediately
congratulate him for his election win
and publicly admits that he
congratulated Vladimir Putin for that
election win and we have learned that
the White House not only put out a
statement saying Trump won't be
congratulating Vladimir Putin but we've
since learned that White House advisors
including reportedly HR McMaster
specifically warned Trump do not
congratulate Putin on his election win
and in fact we don't know if Trump read
it because he doesn't really read the
presidential daily briefings he's
receiving them orally and probably
watching Fox News on a TV in the
background as well but in a written
document in all capital letters Donald
Trump was told do not congratulate
Russian President Vladimir Putin for his
election win when you were on the phone
got it and then we hear the following
from president Donald Trump yesterday I
had a call with President Putin
and congratulating him on the victory we
all had to do also with the fact that we
will probably get together in the
not-too-distant future party so that we
can discuss arms we could discuss the
arms race as you know he made a
statement that being in an arms race is
not a great thing that was right after
the election one of the first statements
he made this is the best first thing I
called him and congratulated him on his
election win uh-oh was right was I not
supposed to do that because it's only
that the White House publicly said I
wasn't going to and I was given a big
capitalised piece of paper that said do
not congratulate him
listen Trump would have had 77 percent
of the vote like Vlad if it weren't for
those millions of people voting
illegally maybe he sympathizes in some
way with the situation that Vladimir
Putin finds himself in and of course the
White House initially saying well listen
we've had these nerve nerve agent
attacks the election irregularities so
Trump's not going to congratulate him as
a because as a consequence of those
things and then not even mentioned
during the call with Putin by Trump the
nerve agent attacks nor the election
irregularities and I wanna just to put
the cherry on top here we only learned
about this initially because the Kremlin
said Trump congratulated Putin during
the call the White House didn't say it
once the Kremlin announced that Trump
had called I guess Trump went out there
and didn't try to deny it and said yeah
you know I did I did congratulate the
guy but it's abundantly clear that aside
from Trump's bumbling the White House
had no intention whatsoever of admitting
that what it announced ended up being
the exact opposite of what happened here
but okay let's at least check whether
Trump is consistent right Trump
congratulated Vladimir Putin but Trump
has never refused to congratulate or
speak to world leaders on the basis that
their elections were shams right oh wait
no that's exactly what Donald Trump did
back in August of 27
when Donald Trump refused to speak with
Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro
stating that Maduro has ignored Trump's
calls to hold free and fair elections
among other requests at the time press
secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said quote the
United States stands with the people of
Venezuela in the face of their continued
oppression
by the Maduro regime president Trump
will gladly speak with the leader of
Venezuela as soon as democracy is
restored in that country does it get any
more absurd than this why even bother
lying about it why even try when you
know that Trump is going to run his
mouth or you're going to have a leak I
do not understand the impetus the desire
to lie about even the absurd details and
in this case blowing up completely in
Donald Trump's face and many discussions
about this happening on the David Pakman
show subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t today's episode of the program
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is really a fantastic and unique
online service that has sort of
reinvented the way people learn math and
science if you watch the show you're
already probably generally curious about
how the world works and you like to
learn new things maybe you have a sort
of casual interest in physics or solar
energy or AI philosophy computer science
but you're ready to take it to the next
level
and whether you already have a grasp on
these subjects or you want to engage and
acquaint yourself with these topics for
the first time brilliant is the place to
go you can actually learn hands-on by
solving problems and puzzles that were
designed by expert educators and
professionals and you can start right
now sign up for free at brilliant org
slash david pakman the first 200 people
who visit brilliant org slash david
pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
forward slash david pakman